et il ya eu encore ce matin une sirène
qui a retenti dans toute la région de
kiev pour demander aux gens de se mettre
à l'abri les raids aériens ont été
meurtriers hier dans tout le pays et
notamment à kiev alors ce que je peux
vous dire c'est qu'autour de la capitale
ukrainienne il y à de très très nombreux
barrages avec des hommes en armes des
soldats d'ukrainiens mais aussi des
volontaires qui ont pris les armes et
qui sont très tendues qui attendent
l'arrivée des russes et donc ses
nombreux barrages servent à filtrer qui
rentre dans la capitale ces soldats ou
ses hommes ouvrent les coffres des
voitures pour vérifier qu'il n'ya pas
d'armes qu'il n'y a pas de drone que ce
ne sont pas des saboteurs russes
infiltrés des hommes russes qui essayent
de rentrer dans la capitale pour
préparer le terrain et pour le semer le
chaos en ville donc de très nombreux
barrages pourra empêcher aussi bien sur
la progression prochaine de ses soldats
russes qui arrive en très grand nombre
vous l'avez dit les gouvernements
occidentaux eux ont invité tous leurs
ressortissants à quitter tout de suite
le coeur de la capitale avant qu'il ne
soit trop tard avant que les russes
commencent à pilonner à la ville c'est
le sentiment général
ici et le pentagone lui déclare a
déclaré ces dernières heures et bien que
le moral n'était pas au plus haut chez
les soldats russes et que de nombreux
soldats russes se demander pourquoi ils
étaient là certains voudraient faire
défection et il y aurait donc des coûts
des problèmes dans de nombreux régiments
russe des russes peut-être des soldats
russes qui ne comprennent pas pourquoi
vladimir poutine les envoyés ici
bonjour clovis que vous disent les
ukrainiens que vous rencontrez on l'a vu
un depuis le début de cette guerre cette
solidarité et cette héroïsme de tous et
ukrainiens
et bien ceux qui ont eu trop peur ont
quitté kiev ces derniers jours mais il
reste beaucoup de gens quand même dans
la ville des gens qui sont terrés chez
eux à cause des attaques mais qui se
prépare qui préparent des cocktails
molotov qui ont pris les armes qui vont
dans les gendarmeries récupérer ces
armes on a vu des hommes prendre des
armes on a vu même parfois des jeunes
hommes des jeunes hommes de 12 13 14 ans
qui sont un petit peu fébrile il faut
bien le dire mais qui ont pris les
fusils qui ont pris les armes pour
défendre la patrie on a aussi rencontré
avec abdallah mal car oui les robes
parsons un jeune homme qui cherche à
rallier kiev qui attend que ses amis
viennent le chercher mais vu que les
couples les russes les routes sont
coupées dans certains endroits et qu'il
y a bien sûr encore des combats et des
bombardements ils ne sont pas encore
arrivés pour venir le chercher lui c'est
un ancien ingénieur il ne sait pas s'il
va combattre s'il va prendre les armes
il a peur mais il est prêt à le faire en
tout cas pour l'instant ils leur île à
acheter des vivres pour les apporter à
ceux qui en ont besoin mais il m'a
déclaré il m'a dit que si les russes
sont dans la ville il n'hésitera pas ce
n'est pas dans sa mentalité ce n'est pas
son état d'esprit de vouloir tuer un
homme mais il est prêt à y faire et
quand il a dit à sa mère qu'il allait
venir à kiev elle a tout d'abord pleurer
mais ensuite à lui a dit mon fils tu
fais la bonne chose pour notre pays